In this video, we'll plot
crime on a map of Chicago.
First, we need to install and
load two new packages, the maps
package and the ggmap package.
So start by installing
the package maps.
So type
install.packages("maps").
When the CRAN mirror
window pops up,
go ahead and pick a
location near you.
When the package is done
installing and you're back
at the blinking cursor, also
type install.packages("ggmap").
When that package is
also done installing,
load both packages using
the library command.
So type library(maps),
and then library(ggmap).
Now, let's load a map
of Chicago into R.
We can easily do this by
using the get_map function.
So we'll call it chicago =
get_map(location = "chicago",
zoom = 11).
Let's take a look at the map
by using the ggmap function.
Now, in your R
graphics window, you
should see a geographical
map of the city of Chicago.
Now let's plot the
first 100 motor vehicle
thefts in our data
set on this map.
To do this, we start by
typing ggmap(chicago).
This is instead of
using ggplot like we've
been using in the
previous videos.
Then we want to add
geom_point, and here, we'll
define our data set to be equal
to motor vehicle thefts, where
we'll take the first
through 100th observations,
and in our aesthetic,
we'll define our x-axis
to be the longitude of
the points and our y-axis
to be the latitude
of the points.
Now, in your R
graphics window, you
should see the map of Chicago
with black points marking where
the first 100 motor
vehicle thefts were.
If we plotted all 190,000
motor vehicle thefts,
we would just see
a big black box,
which wouldn't be
helpful at all.
We're more interested
in whether or not
an area has a high
amount of crime,
so let's round our
latitude and longitude
to two digits of accuracy and
create a crime counts data
frame for each area.
We'll call it LatLonCounts, and
use the as.data.frame function
run on the table that compares
the latitude and longitude
rounded to two
digits of accuracy.
So our first argument to table
is round(mvt$Longitude, 2).
And our second argument
is round(mvt$Latitude, 2).
This gives us the total crimes
at every point on a grid.
Let's take a look at our data
frame using the str function.
We have 1,638 observations
and three variables.
The first two variables,
Var1 and Var2,
are the latitude and
longitude coordinates,
and the third variable is the
number of motor vehicle thefts
that occur in that area.
Let's convert our longitude and
latitude variables to numbers
and call them Lat and Long.
So first, we'll define the
variable in our LatLonCounts
data frame, called Long, and set
that equal to as.numeric, run
on as.character.
Remember, this is how we
convert a factor variable
to a numerical variable.
And we'll give the
variable, LatLonCounts$Var1.
Now let's just repeat
this for latitude.
So LatLonCounts$Lat =
as.numeric(as.character(LatLonCounts$Var2)).
Now, let's plot these
points on our map,
making the size and
color of the points
depend on the total number
of motor vehicle thefts.
So first, again we
type ggmap(chicago) +
geom_point(LatLonCounts, aes(x
= Long, y = Lat, color = Freq,
size = Freq)).
Now, in our R graphics
window, our plot
should have a point for every
area defined by our latitude
and longitude areas,
and the points
have a size and
color corresponding
to the number of
crimes in that area.
So we can see that the lighter
and larger points correspond
to more motor vehicle thefts.
This helps us see where in
Chicago more crimes occur.
If we want to change
the color scheme,
we can do that too by just
hitting the up arrow in our R
console and then adding
scale_color_gradient(low="yellow",
high="red").
If you hit Enter, you should
see the same plot as before,
but this time, the areas with
more crime are closer to red
and the areas with less
crime are closer to yellow.
We can also use geom_tile to
make something that looks more
like a traditional heat map.
To do this, we type
ggmap(chicago), just
like before, but now we're
going to use geom_tile, where
our data frame again
is LatLonCounts.
And in our aesthetic, we
have that the x-axis is Long,
the y-axis is Lat, and
then we have alpha=Freq.
This will define how to scale
the colors on the heat map
according to the crime counts.
Then close the parentheses
and type a comma,
and then type fill="red",
defining our color scheme.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This map takes a minute to load.
While we're waiting,
let's discuss
what we've done in this video.
We've created a geographical
heat map, which in our case
shows a visualization
of the data,
but it could also show the
predictions of a model.
Now that our heat map is
loaded, let's take a look.
In each area of
Chicago, now that area
is colored in red by the
amount of crime there.
This looks more like
a map that people
use for predictive policing.
In the next video, we'll
use data from the FBI
to make a heat map on a
map of the United States.